jason how are you yes sir i'm well you
know all things considered yeah
yeah you i'm i i'm i'm doing well
i like you know i but the big thing for
me is the hair is out of control now
and yeah i feel like i got i feel like i
gotta match it there like
look at that yeah you've got a lot going
on too might as well
if we're both going to do it let's do it
yeah all right well i have
you know i feel like we've done this
before i don't expect you to remember
that because you've talked to a lot of
people but i've only
i've only you know yeah i've talked to a
lot of people and i'm also a sociopath
who has no recollection of my human
interactions
let me begin jason by praising your show
uh i watched i binge watched the
entire season and i loved it and i
watched it with my son and we were
both just completely loving i love the
character of ted lasso it's
really fantastic thanks man that means
the absolute world to me i'm so
flattered and i love that you watched it
with your with your uh
your son that's great yeah you know
what's so nice is we're in this
dark time and what what i'm responding
to
is the show is really funny but also the
character of ted lasso is so
optimistic that i sort of feel like he's
the hero we need right now that's what
i'm taking away from the show like
that's the guy
who i think can get me through kovit i i
appreciate that i i mean
you know what's crazy to me is is the
fact that
there's an argument to be made that
maybe we could have used this guy you
know
four or five years ago too yeah maybe
but right
um but like this whole idea was
conceived
at least for the show in 2015 and my
my my joke had been you know leading up
to
the show finally you know existing much
less premiering is
the big pill you had to swallow as far
as the high concept of it being like a
show about a guy
who could ever believe a show about a
guy who has no idea what he's doing
being in charge of something as
important as a professional soccer team
and like now nobody nobody everybody's
just like yeah yeah this is great
it's exactly like nobody
cares right now you're trying to set
that the stakes are really high that
he's taking over
a mediocre professional uh
you know soccer team in england and
by today's standards that's absolutely
nothing you know
uh yeah it's like oh you'll let that go
i love the show